According to the Oxfam report, the number
of billionaires has doubled in the ten years
since the financial crisis hit.
It also highlights that the 26 wealthiest
people on the planet now own as much as the
3.8 billion people who make up the poorer
half of humanity.
This is unacceptable and there are solutions
and the solutions lie in the hands of government
to tax wealth, to stop tax dodging, to plough
the money into these public services and give
everyone a fair chance to be part of the global
economy.
Oxfam publishes its inequality report every
year shortly before the start of the World
Economic Forum in Davos.
It's an attempt to highlight the issue with
the politicians and business heavyweights
meeting up in the Swiss resort.
But some economists have criticized the study
for implying there are simple solutions to
a complex problem.
Other factors also play a major role in wealth
inequality, they say...for example in the
African nations that are home to some of the
world's poorest.
There, unstable political systems, a corrupt
elite, civil war and poor education structures
continue to have an ongoing impact